ciao ragazzi bentornati in una puntata
di cucina buttata con l'unica differenza
che oggi non sanno in cucina ma siamo
all'interno di una specie di laboratorio
del piccolo chimico oggi creeremo un gel
igienizzante a casa perché
fondamentalmente se andate a trovare i
brand più famosi su internet ormai
vedete che per potervi permettere uno
dovete regalare i vostri figli dare
organi giusto per farvi capire i bei 109
euro prima davvero un peccato che
l'aveva messo a 1.559 euro spero che
avesse sbagliato a mettere qualche
realtà fosse 1,5 euro 555 periodico la
cosa veramente triste poi andare sui
siti di questi prodotti è vedere che i
brand sono costretti a dire guardate che
non stiamo alzando i prezzi sono le
persone che fanno gli sciacalli quindi
prendono prendono prendono tutti quanti
prodotti poi li rivendono anche
illegalmente credo che ogni persona
abbia il diritto di potersi igienizzare
le mani soprattutto un anziano una
persona che va al supermercato e magari
ha bisogno di un flacone per se stesso
senza magari che qualcuno ne abbia presi
100 prima di lui per poter fare una cosa
così ho bisogno di uno specialista non
me la sento di affrontare questo viaggio
da solo perché fino agli anni penso che
fosse molto molto difficile ma sono
recentemente ho scoperto che così non è
ecco perché il piacere di presentarvi un
mio carissimo amico che anche così per
caso un biologo molecolare
sto parlando di raffaele ruberto o
raffaele anche bello averti qui allora
partiamo dal principio di una volta sono
venuto a casa tua
in realtà stiamo parlando di cinque
giorni fa esatto regalo è la prima cosa
che fa è senti prendi questo dico che
cos'è questa cosa qui nome chiedo nelle
mani perché all igienizzante esatto che
buono economia ma con commenti di questo
che ho fatto che carino grazie dove va
comprato nome fa non lo ha comprato lo
ha fatto io mi domando è stato ma come
c'è ma è una cosa tipo di quelle tue
difficilissimo perché magari non sapete
ma raffaele a un brand proprio di skin
kerr molto molto conosciuto in america
che da un anno e anche in italia in
italia naturale prodotti sì sì tutto io
ho detto va bene tu viaggi comunque in
un mondo di ricerca di proprio
millimetrica se tu mi dice che questa
qui è facile
vuol dire che è veramente facile ha
detto mattina di fare un video nel quale
mostriamo come creare
un gel igienizzante a casa tre
ingredienti così proprio tre ingredienti
lo può fare chiunque si chiunque senza
rischiare la vita o cose così no diciamo
che ho preso una versione della ricetta
molto facile che tutti noi scusa in
italiano una meravigliosa che tutti
possiamo fare è trovare anche le materie
prime che importante secondo me non sono
coinvolti ingredienti uffici a reperire
tutti i tre si possono trovare su amazon
tranquillamente di cosa abbiamo bisogno
quindi ok
vogliamo mettere il camice per essere un
po più ufficiale sì sì sì sì sì
verizon figo io della sony bianchino va
bene questo qui il nuovo livello della
mascherina e backing band questa cosa
comunque che cosa faremo oggi abbiamo
tirato fuori il nome di un prodotto che
sarà a buchina con la w di willwoosh e
poi come aggiunta una mancia al 36 la
mia musa è da oggi sono la finanza è
aggiunto anche extra perché poi mi
spiegherei anche per facciamo subito
entrare la ricetta vi presentiamo la
cucina extra questo quella lista di
ingredienti questo qui è il nostro caro
di battaglie che utilizzano quindi al 70
per cento giusto un esatto il motivo in
cui usiamo l'alcol a 70 per cento perché
sul mercato ci sono igienizzante per le
mani che hanno circa 62 64 per cento
dell'auto qui per avere un rinforzo a
buster bia ex power noi abbiamo scelto
di usare 70 per cento in modo che
proprio distruggiamo tutto quello che ci
passante nokia
leggo poi a 25 per cento quindi 25
millilitri di h2o presentarla questa che
e distillata possiamo usare anche volare
il rubinetto si tranquillamente potete
usare quello babbo tuor in bottiglia o
acqua del rubinetto ma anche frizzante 6
idro e cellulosa sapete cosa non ne ho
la più pallida idea
sai cos'è la cellulosa un qualcosa col
no no non ha il camice verdone ma non
sai questo 21 del gruppo la cellulosa è
quella membrana che ti in maniera soda è
una fibra è appena è la parte che da
rigidità alla pianta cioè che non la
fascia dei sarti ok cioè quella che non
è presente nel corpo giorni che resista
del piano prendo a questo qui è l'unico
ingrediente poi mi spiega lee che non è
reperibile su amazon perché è reperibile
tipo c'è pochissimo euro 90 per 1 euro
su un sito specializzato quindi che non
costa niente ma dovete andare a prendere
un'altra esalta quindi questo qui ci
darà alla consistenza più bella perché
se alcuni rischi veramente si sente
raiuno che si vuole dar fuoco
queste benzina e non sempre il fuoco
giusto tempo avrete un ambiente al 5 per
cento di glicerina vegetale la glicerina
vegetale è un mach senso una parola però
una cosa che trae acqua emma youmark un
utente come te numeri ed idratante
umettanti è tanta per il processo
idratazione che dicevi tu un bravo se
non l'auto voti secca la pelle di
distruggere le massime tu sei molto
attento alle mani
le mani sono le estensioni del viso mi
ha detto questo new york vent'anni fa
quando ero piccolo io tante persone
corrono il viso però dimenticherò che
l'atleta si vede pure sulle mani me lo è
si trova tranquillamente premi 8 euro
per un chilo e proprio ricetta base
esatto quindi la profumazione ti faccio
fare dopo dopo quando ci vediamo di
armati e la prima se ti devo fare per
creare la miscela diciamo di acqua
insieme al cellulosa se vedo qui a metà
faccio 25 anni se posso utilizzare anche
i misuratori a casa quelli di chi
assolutamente lui è molto preciso quindi
è questo per un chimico è fondamentale
perché lui e fra poco diventerà un
chimico un collega
questo qua se mettiamo un po di più un
tocco di meno e ciò che per che rende il
gel meno viscosa obbligo si dice è una
cosa che non ti uccide selezionate è una
questione di preferenza di consistente
esatto secondo te qual è l'ingrediente
più preciso di seguire questa rimasto un
pochino con hulk sull'alcol
inconsciamente se l'alcol vero è rimasto
un secondo di più perchè perchè senza
quella lì non disinfettiamo giornali
sono pronto ok 25 mi fermo lì a metà
sono meno missiva incontrare bravo il
mio idolo idro 6 t
jane idro sieti il cellulosa anche io la
uso spesso queste lo sai le mie
preferite ma si può fare
sì si può fare occhio diciamo un grammo
qua ti faccio la tara bravo 1 e 3 perché
la vorrei un pochino più ricca
naturalmente ragazzi ve lo dico subito a
queste qui sono bilance che potete
trovare facilmente non serve che ne
comprate a meno che non facciate un
mestiere come quello lì di raffi o siate
spacciatori quindi è tranquilla per
adesso in questo momento se si guardasse
la polizia di sicuro l'ultima cosa
chiederebbe che stanno cercando di
creare un gel in casa però va bene
questa cui più o meno è la quantità
ok poiché noi mettiamo da parte del 10
15 minuti così le cellulose assorbe
l'acqua si espanda ed insetti valgella
esatto poi diventa crea un metro ex su
una matrice sì adesso possiamo
proseguire ea nessuna l'auto questi sono
70 mentre del bravo capisci capisco che
questa era la mia vocazione tutta la
vita allora lontana dal fuoco giarda
zzzz in realtà non vediamo l'ora di
staccare per andare a giocare
se devono molto secco adesso sì è vero
perché l'auto quando si evapora works
with cioè si porta via d'acqua c'è
l'acqua si salta addosso all'auto e va
via insieme come si dice in realtà
spiegano affetta mente cioè l'acqua si
legga all'alcol e che sarà porta via
ravà positivo quindi in un flacone tipo
questa perso sei un genio
sì ma ero bravo nelle proporzioni e per
questo 6 bravo in cucina perché in
cucina siamo tutti piccolo chimici
chimici cinici anche a cvg che quello
che facciamo noi
puzza vin adesso possiamo misurare è
l'ingrediente che diciamo lega l'acqua
nella pelle non ingredienti della tana
così la l'auto al non porta verdi
datazione misuriamo 5 milite di questo
uno da zucche confusa la viscosità di
sciroppo di acero tipo wow è bellissimo
questo se questo aiuta a mantenere lì
tra d'azione nella pelle
ma questo ve lo posso mettere anche dopo
il saltino
lo so già il trucco quale fa vedevo a
versare questo qua dentro
ne metto un po così suisse switch allo
switch suisse
questo aiuta a risolvere un po la
glicerina bravo
adesso la tua creazione ci credo
la cellulosa ma è pazzesco per il
momento sbattendo tutto in famiglia ma
nikolov e di piega che magari multi loro
capiscono cosa qui è il prodotto abbiamo
messo prima da parte che giustamente è
diventato un gel super denso e quando
verrà aggiunto qui trasformerà questo
composto estremamente liquido in un
qualcosa di gelatinoso simile a questo
bravo o spiegato bene ma come fa trova
farlo cosa dobbiamo il caino esattamente
fare io no non era ovvio che quelli che
ti tiene compagnia a no no ho capito
bach si trova è quello che gli dice fai
questo fai quello che ormai gli dona ha
detto no sì sì e non pil italiano ecco
so now he won han store and a casa
potete usare qualcosa però agitarlo
meglio diciamo che frulla un po possiamo
il mare un frullatore a immersione
potrei utilizzare quello è meglio ancora
speriamo con questo qui vediamo se non
per questo si trova facilmente se tutti
e due in italia vediamo un pochino che
cosa succede nella suite in via o un
autista in questa situazione come si
dice questo possiamo essere coese
l'alchimista puoi modificare la
viscosità del gel in base con letto cui
stoxx vogliamo andare con la sì a me io
sono sempre quello di pulire mai né
pazzesco facciamo finta lo vorrei
capisco non uno di più io quindi lo
aggiungo perché voglio che la
consistenza sia ancora più il già date
nostra
questo è out in a extra guarda la mamma
una piccola nota non rendiamo troppo
viscoso perché poi lascia una patina
sulle mani quindi dobbiamo stare attento
di non superare 2 per cento quindi il
governo sta dal suo 2 per cento
diciamo due e mezzo del massimo
addirittura puoi anche creare forse
questo prenatale puntata puoi anche
creare con questo un gel per i capelli a
4 per cento dai consorzi e lui si è come
ti lascio le mani prima meccano dove
sbaglio l'alcol non è come non ha
lasciato questa è la ricetta base se
volessi però aggiungere un qualcosina
per renderlo più gradevole come a roma
perché hanno tutti degli armeni molto
pungenti che faccio a olio essenziale di
arancio
ok olio essenziale di venirli a questi
sono tutti stati acquistati su amazon
mettiamo tutti i link quanto esso da
naturasì line grazie alla mamma mia è il
mio preferito
così si lava gas in italia non l amico
aspetto in una idea di come si chiami
camera grassa la lehman aggravata questo
con un po di arancia cioè super fra
cromato quantomeno mettere new york a
stare in realtà la profumazione di
routine di una cosa del genere viene a 2
per cento del prodotto finale quindi
sarebbe 2.000 litri per a voi dolly e
ogni 100 grammi questo titolo mi metto
neanche fosse un appassionato della pipa
perché se motivato dalla mia nato 123 e
gli eccessi bottone te perché tu sei un
uomo senza età ti ricordi quel film la
vecchia vecchia
siccome sei una persona che si fa bene
l'epica un sacco con mini classica
quella lì io adesso sono la tua spero si
fidò l'acido ialuronico puro per rendere
le mani senza età accesa aggiungendo
anche quello se voi cosa stessa cosa
perché se ancora la detto poi questo
ragazzi pure per all over jaron polvere
si può trovare anche tranquillamente su
amazon per chiamare la pelle quindi se
vuoi possiamo personalizzare un po noi
abbiamo finito di fare diciamo il
prodotto ma ora sono proprio creando la
wiki next c'è un prodotto inimitabile è
quindi per questa udine extra vorrei
assolutamente acido ialuronico perché
sento che di meritarmelo avevo già
preparato si mischia un polvere con un
po di acqua tipo come abbiamo fatto
prima con il 7 gocce di acido ialuronico
ok super idratante mese in cui il
mercato a casa se volete un tocco più di
idratazione sulle mani cosa abbiamo
tutti in italia poi in modo da olio
d'oliva gr1 viva io ho preso uno di
un'azienda che estrae proprio tutti
principe tv del frutto di oliva quindi
questo non li oliva molto molto puro
cosmetico 6 7 8 9 10 però a casa potete
mettendoli oliva in chi nella macchina
per renderle un po non solo un gel
igienizzante ma anche un qualcosa di
allenamento una volta vediamo se ce la
facciamo che io sono un po una ribalta
di cosa valeva quanto si precisino si
sono preciso schifoso facciamo un altro
per voi o no solo per te questa signora
che mettiamo anche per loro
millecinquecento euro trovate su anno di
pena
ecco questo è dio quindi 2008 a 1800 e
vero che siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa ricetta se seguite i procedimenti
in realtà è tutto quanto molto semplice
non dovete per forza fare quello abbiamo
fatto alla fine le volèe proprio creare
un essenza che mi rappresentasse
io voglio una modella che all'interno di
uno spot burkina catherine solitamente
alla fine di ogni puntata assaggiamo ora
purtroppo non possiamo assaggiare ma
gian marco enrico potete entrare e
provare tutti e due una bookeen extra
costo che ricade metterà il tuo migliore
amico ragazzi ci siete
allora non mi davano come senti l'odore
come l'odore è pazzesco senti pure
quanto è in noi ragazzi e tipo seta per
certi se no come si chiamano li
essenziale si asciuga non lascia la
pelle non appiccicosa e non è neanche
white se catturano che profumo ragazzi
siccome io tengo a voi e al fatto che
voi due dobbiate continuare a rendere
speciale questo canale enrico non ci
credo o non ci credo per te gianmarco 9
reti ragazzi arrivati alla fine di
questo video io ringrazio di cuore
raffoni tu sei un amico marzo è stato di
una disponibilità unica ed è anche una
cosa che abbiamo fatto è bellissima mi
raccomando fate un salto su instagram
vi lascio tutti quanti i link di
raffaele qua sotto vi lascio il link di
tutti ma ti progetti che abbiamo
utilizzato sempre qua sotto e ci vediamo
la prossima settimana martedì con un
blog settimanale alle 12 ciao ciao ciao